alrighty folks so i came across a
trailer for a brand new movie
titled karen and i just i have to share
it with you there's just no way for me
to keep
this much artistic ability
this much joy as much power to myself
behold i guess this is a long way from
east point
baby you just got to give it a chance
[Music]
tell me about your new neighbors they're
black okay pause it right there for a
second i'm sorry
they they first of all they owe jordan
peel royalties
like right away they own jordan peel
royalties right what is this creepy
place oh you mean it's just regular
suburbia first of all everybody needs to
pay stepford wives creators royalties
for
every single movie that has ever been
done that's like this second of all it's
just so on the nose like at least get
out
it's not subtle but it's not like
hitting you in the face of the
sledgehammer in the first 15 seconds of
this trailer first 15 seconds
you know what this entire movie is they
have a new neighbor
so here's the thing about get out it's
supposed to be taking place in this sort
of quasi-realistic universe
this one is like is it supposed to live
in creepy not quite real land or is it
supposed to be super realistic because
as you'll see
they never exactly explain like there's
nothing supernatural happening like the
whole point of get out is there's all
this supernatural weirdness going on
like separate wives
there's nothing supernatural in this
trailer the whole trailer is just a
creepy white lady who hates black people
and it's supposed to be a stand-in for
like all white people or something
there's no one in america
who thinks like this particularly not
white suburban ladies come on man
come on man do you mind keeping it down
if you don't comply i'll tell the
manager
somebody's taking home security serious
hi i am karen drexler i'm your neighbor
you need to be taking your trash cans
off the curb right when the truck how is
this not an
snl sketch i'm sorry how is that not an
snl schedule
this lady who's like playing it super
over the top
you've got the one high note on the
piano
oh my god it's so creepy and she trained
her cameras on their house
which by the way i'm like i'm not sure
if that's super legal or not like if you
just train your cameras on somebody
else's home
i i don't actually know what the legal
standard there is because i guess you're
in public
kind of also she's not clever at all
like she's she's apparently the
stupidest racist in all the land
here are the two examples we have of her
being the dumbest racist ever
number one she's at a restaurant a black
guy is laughing
and she says she's going to report the
black guy to the manager
for laughing too loud now i just have a
question is there a manager of a
restaurant anywhere in america
who would go up to a black person and be
like you're laughing too loud and that
white lady doesn't like it
second thing she's like you need to roll
back your trash can afterward
like your trash can no one is getting
arrested for that
no one this is her big threatening
moment oh white people are like this let
me tell you
we love rules so damn much that if you
don't roll your trash can back
like within the next five minutes after
the garbage truck comes by we'll come
over to your house and threaten you
that's the kind of lawlessness we white
people simply will not abide
let's continue with this it is the worst
trailer i have ever seen my goodness
wait a minute we have a
white entitled neighbor named karen
karen oh no there she is slaving away in
the kitchen
i've come across
oh my god it's so funny okay and so
first of all it's hilarious
we have a white entitled namer named let
me guess
karen so here's where the left gets so
anti-racist they're just racist right
white ladies named karen have to be like
super racist we're gonna make a whole
movie about white
ladies named karen cause there are
actual white ladies named and she walks
in
like here's my subtle pun are you ready
here's my racist subtle pun
there you are slaving away
in the kitchen and everyone's like
what who wrote this dialogue a toddler
like that's your clever pun
seriously she's like what year were you
born in
[Music]
what they respected me for saying it
seriously if you're just gonna be this
obvious about it just be obvious about
it but my goodness
with a sledgehammer gang i've come
across some very
suspecting teenagers
can you please hurry up please it's
either
very aggressive yep i left my wallet
with my id
at home leave a saloon we didn't do
anything how the heck did you end up
moving to this neighborhood
next thing you know we have criminals
you take care of him and i
will take care of her would you mind
stepping out of that okay pause it for a
second first of all i love
that it's like all these teenagers were
doing were filming her
and she called the cops and then all the
teenagers get arrested for apparently no
reason at all
but what walking without id confused
also she's very pissed of trash cans
this lady hates two things more than
anything else black people and trash
cans
hates them despises black people in
trash cans she's like you know
if they move in crime will follow no one
thinks like this okay if a black family
moves in to an upper crust white
neighborhood these houses are enormous
no one is like you know who's coming the
gangs
like what in the world is this bipolar
data this does not exist in the united
states the number of americans who say
that they are happy living next to a
person of a different race in the united
states is higher than any other
industrialized country by pew polling
data
hey like it's okay continue this
nonsense my office has uncovered some
disturbing information on
her and her brother her brother
she doesn't like black people we have a
search warrant
well i'm black i know she
doesn't like you either okay pause it
right there in case you missed the
message
did you miss the message for the first
two minutes of the trailer because this
creepy little girl
will tell you the message and i love the
i love the black lady's response and
it's like
but i'm black yeah we know and also
you're speaking to a child and the
child's like yeah she doesn't like you
what
did you think the child was gonna say oh
yeah but she loves you hates black
people loves you though
i mean really after she's like having
people arrested and i love that she has
a creepy cop brother and the creepy cop
brother is doing all of her
all of her bidding man oh man this this
trailer is just like
even if you're woke you got to be
looking at this and you got to be like
man
how is this not how is this possibly not
a parody how
this is a mainstream big budget flick
how
i want to sell the house what i do you
can't tell me huh
we are living next oh my god a racist
you went in her house you wouldn't want
your wife to know our little secret
okay pause it for a second like um i'm
so she sneaked into their house and put
i'm not kidding you a soap dispenser
with a confederate flag on it you get it
from amazon you can't buy anything with
a confederate flag on it from amazon
but she somehow like went back to
1932 and found a soap dispenser with a
confederate flag on it
and planted it in the black people's
house that's the evilest
thing i can imagine that's her plan
and i love she's like we live next door
to a racist now here's the thing
this whole thing actually actively
undercuts the entire
systemic racism shtick right the entire
systemic racism shtick
is that the systems are racist you're
not particularly racist we don't know if
you're racist or not like not in the
traditional sense and that doesn't
matter when we say this is on the nose
we myth is like on the pinocchio nose
like that like
there are not noses large enough for
this to actually fit upon them
this is so on the nose what do we have
here we
got a hammer everything looks like nails
you people
are very angry shut your mouth
boy
bad things happen to people that don't
comply
[Music]
karen
bad things happen to people who don't
comply
wow wow and it's called karen
that is that's amazing like i gotta
admit that's incredible if that had been
just a sketch on snl making fun of get
out
it would have been amazing but it's an
actual film like there's two hours of
that
i'm gonna have to do some sort of live
watch of this right like there's no way
around it
we're gonna have to do like a live
stream of me just watching this film
because
now i kind of want to see it i'll be
honest with you this is so bad
it's actually a masterpiece of how bad a
movie trailer can be
was this directed by tommy wiseau like
what there has to be a trick here
it can't be real or is it
alrighty folks there you have it karen
the greatest film trailer of all time
at least it's like top three it's like
you know citizen kane
karen t2 maybe really solid stuff there
i i might have to watch it live so let
me know in the comments whether you
would like me to do that with you
because it looks pretty spectacular